the Valley of the Kings a team of
forensic experts is on the trail of
Nefertiti and that lost Amarna dynasty
led by dr. Zahi Hawass Secretary General
of Egypt's Supreme Council of
Antiquities and explorer-in-residence
for National Geographic they've come to
a dark and mysterious tomb known as kV
inside a small side chamber two mummies
they have been there for centuries
without coffins without wrappings some
believe they were moved from the
original resting place hidden away by
priests to protect them from tomb
Raider's both of these mummies have at
times been identified as Queen Nefertiti
some have claimed that she is the body
on the right the so-called elder lady
but recently in press reports around the
world she has been identified as the
mummy on the Left known as the younger
lady some scholars they believe that
this mummy is for Queen Nefertiti if you
are a scientist you cannot announce a
discovery unless you are sure hundred
percent that this is mummy is for Queen
Nefertiti we are now in the beginning of
scientific research to find out for the
first time through the CT scan machine
that can go inside the mummy
tonight the team has come for answers
their goal to get the scientific
evidence that will establish whether
either of these mummies could be
Nefertiti it's a groundbreaking
investigation using the latest
technology a CT scan machine brought in
by National Geographic specifically for
this purpose 21st century Diagnostics
for a mystery 3,000 years old as part of
the first set of CT scans ever performed
on the Royal mummies of Egypt this
non-invasive technology allows
scientists to look inside a body an
unprecedented three-dimensional detail
without doing any harm
dr. Hawass has called in two expert
radiologists dr. Ashraf Salim and after
Hanny aimer to help in the investigation
it is a mysterious mummy
but today maybe we'll be able to find
out exactly that this money is for Queen
Nefertiti and maybe is not for the Queen
the idea of this so-called younger lady
as Nefertiti has been a source of
controversy in recent years some
scholars make the claim based on several
clues the most important a broken arm
found in nearby wrappings the hand once
clenched a scepter the symbol of
ultimate power in ancient Egypt the sign
of a pharaoh or a queen other clues in
the identification an indentation from a
headband and double pierced ears all
seem to match the last known images of
the Queen but many scientists have
argued the case is purely circumstantial
my reaction when the news broke that
Nefertiti's been discovered was complete
rubbish as far as I can see is
absolutely no possibility whatsoever
that mummy could be Nefertiti there's a
lot of princess Moses time probably a
hundred so it can can be any of this
princess
Nefertiti wasn't just any princess to
track her down you have to understand
who she was one of the great icons of
the world born into nobility growing
into a beauty she was chosen by the
Pharaoh Akhenaten to be his bride
their love became the stuff of legend
literally carved into the stones of
Egypt they had six daughters together
according to some scholars Akhenaten may
have really not just wife and queen but
eventually co-regent Akhenaten wanted to
present Nefertiti somebody who was
sharing her with him there are a few
reliefs in which very unusually indeed
she's shown smiting Egypt's enemy as if
she's on the same military footing as
her husband but whether or not they rule
together both shared the same fate
disappearing into the sands of Amarna